we have Tom Willis and NAT Duca they are
on the chrome graphics team and hack all
day on the graphic stack they're
dedicated to making us developer
understand what's going on so that you
can make sure that your apps are fast
fluid and awesome and then
simultaneously dedicated to improving
that platform so that you don't have to
work so hard to do that and you just get
it for free
I'm really excited and please please put
your hands together for NAT and Tom
hello everyone my name is Tom will seus
as Paul said I'm NAT Duca nice to see
everybody here yeah and we're from the
chrome graphics team I'm gonna use the
yeah laptop instead of their clicker so
we can play videos we're here today to
talk about rendering performance and we
want to start off with a few basics that
we're not going to cover in much detail
because there is a ton of great content
available on the web about this stuff
already we've talked about it before
other folks on our developer relations
team have talked about it before but we
wanna make sure we're on the same page
so the pages that we want you to be on
are the following right you got the the
screens here lots of them they're all
running at about 60 Hertz but maybe not
16 milliseconds is a number that you
want to keep in your mind
we heard Ilya talking about numbers much
bigger than 16 milliseconds so this is a
much smaller time frame but it's super
super important that if you want to be
smooth you've got to hit that budget
that's right and there's a lot of stuff
that needs to go into that 16
milliseconds the rendering system is
really complicated we're gonna walk
through kind of the various stages in
the rendering pipeline in this talk but
it's challenging to fit everything into
16 milliseconds and this means that you
should be working with the browser
whenever possible
this means using things like
requestanimationframe rather than a
timer to to run animations this means
using things like CSS animations when
possible rather than doing everything
yourself and JavaScript and yeah just
like trying to play nice please be nice
there's more content available at those
links yeah so
you know we all know and we've known for
many years that if you have good load
times for your pages your user
engagement will be much better than if
you have bad load times there's another
part of this business that we don't talk
about but that's obvious to mobile
developers which is your responsiveness
right we've got two videos here going
that are you know a good responsive page
that is smooth and one that's janky
right
you've got to think of this as a first
order part of your business as creating
a web app I think most of you know this
but it's really worth hammering that
home up to the bosses that this is
something you don't fix at the end you
think about throughout the lifecycle of
whatever it is that you're building
that's right and and especially we're
going to talking a lot today about sort
of things that impact mobile devices
more than they impact say like this
laptop and this kind of difference this
difference in responsiveness but the
difference comes out much more on said
mobile devices right this is one of the
key distinctions between native
application development platforms on
Android or iOS and and the mobile web is
that thing's feel webby
when they like when they're slow when
they're jittery and your users are going
to notice the difference even if they're
not conscious of it it doesn't feel as
nice it's one of the the tells so to
speak of of a web app and that's that's
unfortunate that's what we want to avoid
so we've been nice in that let's talk
tech that's right and so we're gonna go
through if any of you have seen us to
talk before we're gonna go through sort
of some content that should be fairly
familiar about how the painting system
works how the compositing system works
and then we're going to talk about some
stuff that we haven't talked about
before so with that in mind we're gonna
go kind of fast but but bear with us if
you think about how pixels get on the
screen of say mobile phone there's a
whole slew of stuff that needs to happen
from the perspective the JavaScript it's
all of this stuff yeah so this this sort
of thing makes the actual chrome
engineers try to kill themselves because
it's all a lie but from the point of
view of a web developer there are these
various pipeline stages that your
content goes through you start off with
your J s and your DOM it has to be
styled that has sort of two big steps
layout and recalc style the first parts
where you're taking all your CSS
selectors and figuring out which apply
to what second part is figure
where things are positionally eventually
you've got all that stuff done you're
still not done you've got to basically
take all of that computed stuff and turn
it into actual pixels RGB values in
memory somewhere or on a GPU and we do
that in two parts right now first we
paint which is where we take all the
lines and we rasterize them and the
second part is we take all those
textures that we made and we smash them
together on the screen using the
compositor and that's the stage where
you hear the layers come about that's
right and so you can actually see this
pipeline in action in dev tools we
really really like the dev tools
Timeline view because it not only shows
you each of these pipeline stages kind
of happening but it also shows you how
long each stage took which means that
you have some sense of where the time
may be eaten up if you you have some
janky
interaction on your page and usually the
first thing I do when I'm trying to
debug some slow site for whatever reason
is I open it up I take a timeline
recording of whatever it was that was
slow and I start to get some sense of
the breakdown of where that time is
going and what it is that's causing a
lot of time to be eaten this is your
first line of defense really when it
comes to jank busting that's right and
if you think about what properties you
can animate in CSS you know CSS will let
you animate whatever you want right but
it's it's important to realize that not
all of these things are created equal if
you change something like the opacity
value on on some element then all we
need to do behind the scenes is
recompose it turns out compositing is
fairly cheap we can do it on the GPU and
and we can composite every frame no
problem in fact chrome needs to
composite every frame just to make a new
screen image but then you compare that
to something like width or top and all
of a sudden you you you modify the width
property and maybe some text reflows we
need to do a lot of relay out and
everything that got real laid out and
maybe more stuff around it needs to be
repainted and then everything that got
repainted needs to be recomposed and all
the sudden this whole pipeline is kind
of in action which is very difficult to
fit in 16 milliseconds you're now in
danger territory that's the more left
you go in this pipeline the more you're
risking jank
yeah but that's it
it's not just the more left there's it's
kind of a big cliff right about on air
right about there
one of these things is not like the
others painting is really slow it's like
really slow and and we wanted to share
some numbers right so so this is data
from chrome perf which is the dashboard
that was mentioned earlier this morning
we have like a rasterization time metric
and if you look at a nexus 10 and you
take a site like the New York Times
takes 10 milliseconds to raster just the
content that's currently visible say
during the page load so that's better
I mean 10 is is not yeah okay sure fine
like about this but because then you go
to a site like the verge and all of a
sudden it takes 107 milliseconds this is
not fast right and then you go to cute
overload and it takes 214 milliseconds
to raster right it's a lovely sight
right right nothing nothing I'm not
pooh-poohing any of these sites I'm just
saying like there's there's an
incredible amount of unpredictability in
how long things take to paint and if you
think about this in terms of frames
which is kind of a good logical unit to
consider then all the sudden you can see
that 214 milliseconds that's that's 13
frames at 16 milliseconds of frame that
means that you end up in this position
where if you really want to be
repainting all that content every frame
there's just no way right it's per frame
this means that your frames per second
it goes goes way way way down you're
nowhere near 60 or is that smooth right
and this is this is exacerbated when as
I kind of alluded on the last slide you
end up in this position where you need
to paint things on a per frame basis so
we call this a paint storm if you go
into dev tools and you turn on show
paint rectangles you'll get a red flash
on the part of the screen that Ray
paints every time a tree paints this is
cool because it means that you can see
that during this interaction this is
Nats fat-finger kind of moving up and
down on an online demo you made you can
see that there are key points in that
interaction where all the sudden they're
these red flashes that show up and and
cover the screen and this is really bad
right because that means
every time one of those red flashes
shows up then we're paying a lot of this
significant paint cost right and if you
were to show a sort of like a timeline
view of this in developer tools you'd be
able to see exactly how long each of
those paints were taking yeah so you
know and we see a lot of sites that
basically get pretty far along in their
lifetime before they even look at paint
rects you know and at that point you've
added so much complexity to your Dom
you've got 73 different things all going
on you'd no longer know which is the one
that's causing the storm what's going
wrong and so you you you want to keep
your eye out for this from the beginning
of your content through its lifetime in
order to defend against this now the
defense you know the first line of
defense in this space is layers right
we've alluded to it we've talked a lot
about it on jank-free you can look at
that demo and think about it in your
head and go well you know these pieces
and they're just moving around so what
we can do to make this smoother is keep
each one of those in a layer and sort of
add them all together and if you sort of
think about then the movement from frame
to frame to frame is us just moving
these layers around on the screen no
repainting is necessary so that means we
don't have to get those left parts of
the pipeline running that are slow the
purples and the Pitt the greens and and
so in theory this this is smoother right
and so this is just the the same thing
but redone to be no repaints or very few
and so it's a lot smoother yeah and
actually you can see it's probably
pretty small on the screen but you can
see that there are some red flashes
still happening along the far right side
of the mobile device screen that's just
us repainting the scrollbar which we do
at bars we have an optimizer they're
small but you can see that other than
that there there are no no red flashes
right this is this is good the point
here is that you you want to try to
decompose the the the structure of your
page into kind of logical units that map
well to layers and these logical units
should be things that move together that
fade together or that maybe stretch
together these are things that are sort
of easy to express in terms of the
layering triggers that we have on the
web platform today should make a
postcard that says yeah together I'm
stretched and and basically this maps to
the set of things this maps to the set
of things that GPUs are good at right
GPIOs are okay at the kind of
rasterization that not was talking about
earlier but they're really good at these
bulk pixel operations yeah so think in
terms of layers it's really really sort
of that key building block right now for
getting speed on mobile but that having
been said great right what sucks about
this watching things about this we
we try to make layers automatically but
we can't always do it right like one of
the common questions we get is always
okay so great I I see how you guys are
explaining the rendering system working
like why can't the browser do all of
this on my behalf and believe me if we
are trying but there there are some sort
of fundamental limitations that though
we more or less can't get over the most
mundane of these in my mind is is text
anti-aliasing you'll you'll drop from
sub-pixel like LCD screen text
anti-aliasing to grayscale text
anti-aliasing ClearType yeah if you're
on a composited layer that doesn't have
a solid color background so if you're
concerned about text quality then and
and you may be manually provided
something to a layer try to make it a
solid color background you won't have
that problem this is the same reason we
we have different criteria for
automatically promoting certain content
two layers on high DPI versus low dpi
devices and on android versus desktop so
you need to be testing all of these
places this sucks this really does not
only it does not what we can do about it
there are other things too so for
example position sticky is one of the
looks du jour right and and
understandably so when you try to
emulate that a lot of the times what you
end up having is you have a div that
you're moving up and down and inside it
you want a position fixed sort of child
of that div that's your sticky element
unfortunately when you put translate z0
on that that redefines at the spec level
what the position fixed is relative to
if you go and do a little jsfiddle on
your own you'll find that position fixed
on something that is a layer is through
to translate c0 is relative to the
actual layer so then you can't do who's
sticky because you want sticky to stick
to the viewport if you use this nasty
little dirty trick you might have more
headway and we're gonna leave it sort of
at that because this is unblessed but
the reality of the world we live
and this is this is in fact reality this
is the web right and there's another
little unfortunate reality so you know
big tall web web pages are tall right
you've got lots of things in them you
know ten thousand twenty thousand pixels
tall is not unusual Chrome's rendering
system uses layers in order to warm
things up so we we are looking at all
layers assuming that they might come
onto screen imminently has anybody ever
done a trick in their app where they put
something at negative ten thousand
pixels and then they fly it in with an
animation right it looked really pretty
but the problem with that is we Chrome
have no idea if something is negative
ten thousand pixels from the viewport
and can't become visible next frame yeah
versus it's negative ten thousand pixels
and the user can't get there okay so
this is a thing where this we don't have
that understanding so if you hide stuff
that the user can't get to anytime soon
that gives us less work to do we use
less CPU and you're less janky yeah and
that's that's all really good so okay
this is this kind of a lot of content
that we just blew through and we didn't
do any kind of live live demos the way
we usually do but I want to break this
down to some simple takeaway messages
which is that you want to be looking for
these paint storms you can find them
with dev tools and the show paint recs
function if you if you find these these
paint storms you want to try to avoid
them through implicit or explicit layer
creation if at all possible you can see
the layer borders really nicely if you
go into dev tools and turn on show
composited layer borders this is a very
nice visual aid to to help you with this
sort of layered decomposition process
and if you're still if you're doing
everything right and you're still
finding that you you have these these
paint storms and you just can't figure
out why it's repainting because it
doesn't seem like anything needs to you
maybe you may be right
chrome isn't perfect we we've spent a
lot of time making this just work there
are cases where Chrome's tiny little
brain or blinks tiny little brain gets
confused and it repaints in the universe
if you're hitting that try to reduce it
down pare it down and email Tom or I or
file a bug try to get that's we've been
we've been recently on a spree of
stamping out like what we call
experienced paint invalidations and we
would
we would love to have more bugs welcome
that's right okay so that's that's
rendering performance from the
perspective of JavaScript right but if
what we really want to talk about is is
responsiveness on a touch based device
like a mobile phone there's there's
another there's another component to the
entire story that we haven't really
talked about yet and that's and that's
the input right particularly on a touch
device latency can be absolutely killer
and and that's gonna walk through a
couple examples of that we got two
videos going here good in the bad right
this this sort of should jump right out
at you if you drag this something around
with your finger you want it to stick to
your finger and on the left you've got
something that's definitely not sticky
feels a little laggy if you're doing
this yourself on the right is sort of a
little closer to what you want and
ideally you get even even even closer as
you know as much as you can right now
getting to there on the web that's the
leading edge of innovation for both
chrome and really every will everyone
this is a hard problem yeah but we'd
like to share what we know about it
today right and a little bit about what
we've been doing so if you're if you're
trying to get the page to stick to your
finger or say maybe you have like a
slider widget and you really want the
slider widget to stay under your finger
when you slide the widget around then
you've kind of got two options option a
is you you get lucky and you happen to
have an effect that can be expressed in
terms of the fast scroll path if you're
on if you're on this fast scroll path
and the browser is is sort of doing the
scrolling for you then you just happen
to get all of the best like the best
possible touch input latency because we
built that part and we sure had to make
it as good as possible but the option
beasts sort of happens when you're in a
situation we got to implement a drawer
or a slider where the actual thing or a
drawing app the actual thing that
happens in response to that input is
necessarily programmatic that is not a
scroll you need to handle that yourself
there's a different set of rules for
making that fast that's right so let's
say you go with option A and right and
and often that totally works start
depending on your content like scrolling
the reason we sort of have done all this
work about scrolling as it's rolling is
like one of the most
and operations on the web right and and
even on on mobile devices so if you're
gonna go this route you want to make
sure that the layers you sort of expect
to have gotten created were in fact
created and that they're working as
intended so this means that whatever the
the kind of Content area that is
scrolling should be in its own layer and
when it Scrolls you shouldn't see it all
repainting right and again it's the same
the same couple of basic dev tools
features will will let you very easily
visualize this along with timeline we're
just hitting this point again which is
layers are good but they're very hard to
persuade to exist yeah and so you have
to be sort of constant vigilance here
right order to catch that fast path
exactly and a lot of that vigilance
comes down to testing the right places
so it is very tempting as as a developer
to to do everything on your laptop right
or on your workstation but the
unfortunate reality is it's it's
basically impossible to emulate the
performance characteristics of a Android
device on say this nice laptop that's
not just to do with CPU versus GPU speed
etc but it has a lot to do with the fact
that chrome actually will behave
slightly differently on Android than it
does on desktop the DPI matters and all
of this is is subtle and that's
unfortunate but the reality is like
building high-performance rendering
systems is is complicated and you need
to test on target devices so if you do
hit the fast path you're in a good
position we're doing a lot of work to
make that feel less laggy Chrome has
been particularly kind of not good at
that notice I didn't say bad but you
know we've got a lot that are working
hard to make that better but that is the
case for native scrolling right so what
about option B so okay I'm gonna attempt
to do a little bit of footwork here the
to try to say how you can't make this
work this is really bleeding edge if you
want to do something with a touch
listener and be smooth you have to do
these two things you got to keep all of
your costs all of them to less than
seven milliseconds and you have to avoid
foot guns will push stack on the foot
guns and talk about why why why not
sixteen because I felt like it yeah okay
we have chrome running and then we have
your code and we're sort of sharing that
that system in order to
zero latency we have to run your stuff
then our stuff all in that 16
millisecond budget and oh by the way the
operating system also is there doing
stuff and this is the kind of thing that
you don't generally worry about on on
say like a laptop because there's sort
of enough performance overhead that you
don't really worry about what Windows is
doing in the background but in fact on
like most modern mobile phones even the
they're so resource constrained that
actually some system thing coming in and
running candy schedule all of the
browsers threads and then back crap so 7
keep that in mind keep your stuff so
that this essentially means don't paint
at the moment don't pay don't do heavy
js2 is sort of minimal j/s as you can
you know if you've got a layout and be
very careful and avoid recalc style if
not possible okay foot guns so this is
another one of those laundry slides of
like there's that nice theoretical world
that we talk about unless here's all the
caveats the the first one is probably
the craziest if you if you want to do
this right if you want to handle touch
events yourself in JavaScript that means
you need touch event listeners right if
you're gonna have touch event listeners
be judicious about when and where you
install them particularly be wary of
installing touch listeners during the
page load or you will risk scrolling
jank and unpredictable delivery of those
touch events so we're simplifying a very
complex message with this general rule
and we'll come back to it later about
the details of it but just keep this in
mind
big listeners touch listeners in general
have a lot of scary yeah touch ends this
is also complicated actually
so if you drag your finger off a screen
do you get a touch touch end or a touch
cancel what yeah so there's this common
set of problems where people forget to
listen to touch cancel and so they get
basically really weird behavior in the
field and they can't figure out what's
going on they forgot to listen to touch
cancel it's a minor point but very
important because people will say that
you're being janky and the reality is
you just forgot to get that one of that
we're so trained to think Mouse down
mouse move Mouse up you know all of us
grew up like that so this is a bit of an
adaptation yeah the 300 millisecond tap
delay has been mentioned in other talks
and
and will be pounded on more and this is
to disambiguate between double tap to
zoom and a click and yes this is crappy
and yes the browser tries to not wait if
if it can determine it's impossible to
zoom set your viewport tag correctly if
you don't care about yeah just be
careful there's a lot of good content
online about this one so we won't talk
about it too much
and lastly mouse wheels mouse wheel is
obviously not so much relevant on mobile
more relevant on on desktop platforms
but mouse wheel listeners have a lot of
the same problems that touch listeners
do so so less you think that this is
sort of limited to touch in fact you can
show yourself in the foot with with with
mouth feel listeners and there's some
major web sites that actually have touch
listeners and so they technically could
hit the the all these fast paths we've
been talking about about latency except
they have a mouse wheel listener they
don't do anything in an ironic nope but
they're they've shot themselves and
there's nothing we can do about it yeah
these are all this is all like SPECT or
de facto standard behavior which means
that there's this is not going to change
it's a wild world out there it is yeah
so so remember we started off with a
video of sort of a janky finger moving
this thing on so imagine your p.m. is
like hey I want you to make that logo
thing draggable because I your boss and
I'm gonna make you do it so you're a
good doobie and you go coded up right
you put a document dot out of it
listener touched begin and add
eventlistener touch move and you're like
look it works it's awesome and then you
get these reports from the field and
they're like yo this is really janky
like I can't use my page I love that
thing but like you destroyed your page
you go to these options and dev tools
and you show scroll bottlenecks this is
what you'll see on the left with a
global document listener what's happened
is you've told chrome that you your
JavaScript wishes to preempt any input
received by the user right into
JavaScript all the time we cannot think
about doing anything with your input do
any sort of fanciness that we can do
until you say yes or no specifically you
say prevent default or to fail to
prevent default that event and so if
you're gonna listen to touch you need to
do it on the most specific thing you can
do and
because of this whole prevent defaulting
thing remember the thing we push it onto
the stack earlier about that mysterious
don't add touch from before load it's
the same thing if you have an input
Handler and you've you've told chrome
that then any any time you touch the
thing that has the handler you get
automatic preempt over anything we can
do which means that if the browser is
busy doing something like recalc style
we can't do anything in response to user
input and so you again get a jack that
means we can't scroll until your touch
listener runs or we timeout and we give
up so be very very careful about when
and where you install these these
listeners yeah not good ok we've only
got five minutes left and we want to
talk through a little bit of kind of
where we come from in terms of the
chrome rendering stack and and more
importantly where where we're going if
you you've seen us give talks before
you've you've probably heard us
caveat some of the differences between
desktop platforms and Android etc and
there are still differences as we
mentioned before but these days that's
more about sort of like the actual power
of the device and less about the
rendering architecture this is really
good because it makes your lives easier
as developers it makes our lives is your
building Chrome and the sort of pace of
of that catch up of other platforms is
accelerated and in the last year's so we
have a lot of really fancy technology
that enables us to run smoothly on
Android and it's unevenly deployed right
now it's a lot better in chrome 32
hugely better but it's still not there
so this is why we continue to recommend
testing on all the platforms you intend
to support at least for now at least in
terms of Jack because of these
non-uniformities it's the world we live
in
yeah the Android webview though is new
and and it's further bringing everything
in line we wish though to share some
things with you because it's not also
web yet list of caveats there is a rich
tradition on the Android webview to
disable hardware acceleration there were
good reasons for this an Android webview
there still are some good reasons to do
this with the Chrome based webview but
fewer and different we're not going to
explain the that sort of curvature space
directly but the thing is please if you
were in the past disabling
acceleration on your webview please
revisit that decision check it your
content out in chrome webview see if
it's better if it is chrome will reward
you in scores it's the hardware based
rendering is really really good compared
to the software one another important
caveat this is a difference there are
differences between chrome itself on
Android and the webview one of the most
significant is that the Dom size matters
a lot more chrome tries to be smart
about culling stuff that's way away from
the viewport but this gets a lot easier
if the developer just says no this is
this is right out invisible this is
particularly relevant to the webview
because the webview has a part of the
webview api contract is you can ask for
the whole document which means that
every time we go to record things to
paint later we have to record the entire
document we can't do any of the
smartness around calling that we're
trying to do this means that we incur a
lot more memory and so you need to be
careful about this so you want to try to
do your own viewport if at all possible
yeah and and this is just that basic
thing maybe someday we'll revisit that
but please keep it in mind and just sort
of a more broad thing like jank busting
and a webview Android sort of combined
app means keeping the UI thread free for
both components they're sharing the same
thread
you've got great tooling to show which
one's eating the eating time but you got
to keep an eye on both there's nothing
that we've got that protects you against
yanking each other that's right so where
are we going next there are these fast
paths but it's hard to get on to them
and it's easy to fall off of them we we
think this sucks just as much as you
guys do and we want to make it better
through a combination of improving
chrome and improving Chrome's tooling so
about tooling I mean so you've seen a
couple little pictures like this where
we tilt the webpage to the side we think
that these things these questions need
to be easily and without a lot of
thought answerable for you all to be
more productive it should be possible to
see the layers it should be possible to
see why something became a layer why
something didn't become a layer you
should see your scroll bottlenecks none
of this should be so hard as it is now
and it certainly shouldn't be a soup of
checkboxes yeah it's becoming visually
inspect this so mr. Paul Richard Irish
is going to be talking about this in
more detail tomorrow that's right me
while there there's a lot that we can do
behind the scenes to keep making chrome
faster and this is there's a lot of
people working on this we're trying to
fix a lot of the a lot of the issues
that make the slow stages and the
pipeline's so slow so if you can't just
express yourself in terms of compositing
operations there are some basic changes
to layout that actually should be very
cheap right
why can't you move something around with
top if it if it's absolutely positioned
it doesn't affect anything else like in
theory this should work but like blink
is just not that smart and so we're
trying to we're trying to sort of
improve that and there's a slew of
things along those lines that are just
under optimised and so we're gonna start
thinking about but in parallel with that
we're also starting to sort of get out
of the mana focus that we've had for the
last two years to try to just survive
the transition to mobile we've been just
trying to scroll a web page basically
and that was hard it's surprisingly hard
we are now getting to a point where we
can to contemplate what what should the
mobile web really be from a Jag
perspective how do you all want to
express your intent to the browser so
that we do the right thing from the
beginning we put up a list of
intentionally provocative ideas here
just to whet your appetite if anybody
has other ideas if you've got if you've
got strong opinions about one of these
if one of these makes you want to storm
out of the room stay and storm out of
the room after you tell me why you hated
it yeah we must make this better and you
know the reason is we know that it's not
good enough and we know that now that
we've got scrolling sort of figured out
we need to go and make the tools better
we need to make this more accessible we
need to make just jank on the web sort
of a solved you don't think about a
problem yeah that's right
so with that we're gonna wrap up thank
you very much for your time and
attention I'm Tom and this is Matt and
thanks again Cheers